Willkommen im schönen Tirol.
Ich bin hier mit dem Kommandanten verabredet und pünktlich auf die Minute ist er auch schon hier.
Robert, herzlich willkommen hier am Truppenübungsplatz Lizum, bei den Gebirgsjägern.
Danke vielmals.
Ich habe schon gesagt, wer hoch hinaus will ist hier genau richtig.
Absolut.
Was sind denn die vorwiegendsten und wichtigsten Aufgaben der Gebirgsjäger?
Wir halten, nehmen Gelände in Besitz, Verteidigen, wir schützen, unsere Stärke liegt aber darin
unter diesen Umfeldbedingungen und in diesem Gelände die Aufträge zu erfüllen.
Das heißt was härteres als die Gebirgsjäger gibt es kaum.
Das stimmt, ein bischen Härte in der Seele braucht man.
Dann schlage ich vor, probieren wir aus wie es mit meiner Leidensfähigkeit so aussieht.
Sehr gerne, deine Bekleidung passt aber du brauchst ein wenig Ausrüstung hier.
Die Ausrüstung! Das ist meine Ausrüstung!
Robert tut mir leid, es ist der Rucksack nicht das Quad.
Der Rucksack ist auch schön.
Ich nehme an da ist alles drinnen was ein
Gebirgsjäger braucht.
Handschuhe danke, Helm auch ganz wichtig und ich denke ohne das gehts in den Bergen nicht.
Das Lawinen-Verschütteten-Suchgerät,
Hauptgefahr neben den Witterungsbedingungen ist eben die Lawinenverschüttung.
Ausrüstung habe ich, jetzt möchte ich auf den Berg.
Ich hole jetzt noch mein Snowboard.
Das Snowboard ist nur für die Abfahrt, hier brauchst auch du einen Ski für den Aufstieg
und eine Gebirgsjägerin wird dir das zeigen.
Ich glaube ich sehe Sie auch schon.
Die stürzt sich da schon runter, bist du gescheit.
Na dann.
Grüß dich Robert!
Servus, Grüß dich.
Ich habe gesehen Ski und Stecken hast du schon mitgebracht.
Ja, ist alles noch da.
Ich werde dir jetzt beibringen wie wir uns
im Hochgebirge bewegen.
Schauen wir einmal, dass ich etwas erlerne.
Gut, legen wir los.
Wie beim normalen spazieren gehen, der Ski wird nicht angehoben, sondern er wird nur
nach vorne gebracht und probieren so weit wie möglich zu schieben.
Im Gebirge gibt es natürlich nicht nur Pisten, ganz im Gegenteil,
es geht auch die steilen Wände hinauf.
Robert, genau, da sind wir, wir müssen einfach in einem schwierigen Gelände,
einem vereisten Gelände, hinaufkommen.
Auf gehts, rein mit den Steigeisen.
Dran bleiben.
Warum mache ich das?
Sauber Robert, wunderbar.
Danke.
Abseilen, bitte zu mir raufkommen.
Genau, einfach bei mir festhalten jetzt.
Mit dem Rücken in Abseilrichtung, wir seilen da entlang hinunter.
Lehne dich zurück und halte dich bei mir fest.
Seil ist frei!
Noch mehr Resepkt für die, die das Hauptberuflich machen mit der Ausrüstung und allem drum und
dran und weitaus höher, das als Beruf...
Auch in dieser Truppe gibt es natürlich Spezialisten für alle Fälle.
Z.B. ausgebildete Flugretter.
Unsere Soldaten haben schon Vorarbeit geleistet von unserem Hotel.
Es ist noch nicht ganz fertig aber wir haben bereits den Zimmerschlüssel da.
Darf ich ihn dir geben?
Bitte.
Wunderbar, bitte sehr!
Sehr lustig.
So, fertig.
Robert, herausen sind wir jetzt fertig.
Na dann.
ISO-Matte und Schlafsack.
Pyjama anziehen und ab ins Bett.
Gute Nacht.
Gute Nacht Robert.
Tagwache, frischer Tee zum munter werden.
Heiß!
Dankeschön.
Morgen.
Morgen!
Gebirgskampf findet natürlich im Gebirge
statt, den Kampf habe ich heute auch.
Alleine das Lager ist schon auf 2000 meter Höhe, jetzt sind wir noch einmal ein paar
hundert meter weiter darüber wo gerade eine Lawninensprengung stattfindet.
Was ist das jetzt eigentlich, eine klassische Lawinensprengung oder?
Wir schauen, dass wir die Wechte wegbekommen und die löst dann meistens eine Lawine aus
und dann fahren wir mit den Ski hinunter.
Fertig zum Zünden.
Zünden!
Achtung, Zündung!
Brennt.
So, Sprengung erfolgreich durchgeführt, die Kollegen fahren auf Ski hinunter.
Warum?
Weil sie es können.
Gestern habe ich mich mit einem Soldaten unterhalten, der hat mir erzählt, er hat vor 20 Jahren
die Entscheidung getroffen zu dieser Truppe zu stoßen
und das war die beste Entscheidung seines Lebens.
Er hat hier jeden beruflichen und persönlichen Traum verwirklicht.
Ich verstehe was er meint.
Das ist wirklich eine ganz besondere Truppe.
Hier im Schnee bei Eiseskälte, teilweise
unter widrigsten Bedingungen klettern, sprengen,
die Rettungseinsätze, Assistenzeinsätze
z.B. beim Lawinendienst, das Verteidigen der
Landesgrenzen mitten im Nirgendwo, wo der Schnee 5 meter hoch liegt.
All das sind Dinge, die sind einfach wahnsinnig beeindruckend.
Ich bin so fertig und ich brauche noch mindestens ein Jahr bis ich das Abseilen verdaut habe.
Deswegen verabschiede ich mich hier aus den Tiroler Bergen.
Du nimmst mich mit?
Wunderbar.
Danke fürs dabei sein, alles Liebe, Tschau!